we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here's a caller who wants
me to rank the soy boys listen to this
happy New Years cat girl
uh I have a serious question for you and
you have to answer truthfully by the way
the nickname there was pack girl for
those that not Pac-Man
pack girl very very uh impressive
truthfully
who is the bigger soy boy of the three
okay is it you
pathan nail polish Piper okay or destiny
ah answer truthfully please okay thank
you who is the biggest soy boy is it me
all right this is me
is it Hassan who wears nail polish
says this caller does Hassan wear nail
polish I don't know don't care or is it
Stephen Kenneth
Destiny benel II a well-known
cuban-american streamer
um I think the biggest soy boy
is definitely
uh me I don't know
um this is the type of stuff that the
right is concerned with soy boy and
um various uh insults and for those who
don't know if I understand the soy boy
insult correctly it's a right-wing
insult that takes the idea that liberals
is it that liberals don't eat meat or
something or that they like tofu I'm not
even really sure and soy Becomes
emblematic of lack of strength meat is
strength soy is a cheap
uh alternative I think that that's
the whole idea of soy boy these people
have real problems that I I'm sure that
you can tell we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today Joe Biden recently
questioned why police always shoot with
deadly force we're going to talk about
that on the bonus show we also are
seeing more States push for ranked
Choice voting in 2023 we will review
what is ranked Choice voting what are
its advantages what are its
disadvantages is it possible that we
will get to more widespread ranked
Choice voting nationally very
interesting topic and lastly Republicans
are now justifying their latest attack
on Social Security saying listen people
want to work longer let's raise the
retirement age because at the end of the
day it's what people want people want to
be working longer is that true but more
importantly is that a valid reason to
justify raising the retirement age all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
and make money let's do it everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad that's right Alex let's go make
money on the bonus show you can sign up
at
joinpakman.com you will get instant and
I really do mean instant access to the
bonus show you will get the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
every day hours before we publish them
for everybody else just by virtue of
being a member and we are days away from
launching the member sound board I have
received so many requests from people to
make a soundboard for our members that
mimics my soundboard where I play the
clips
exactly
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines we have built it we
are populating it with the clips soon
members will have access to my
soundboard it's a beautiful and exciting
thing you can sign up at joinpakman.com
I will see you on today's bonus show or
otherwise right back here tomorrow